at a South Carolina Marina locals film
what's believed to be debris recovered
from the Chinese balloon this will be a
spectacle for days beachcombers urged to
hand in anything they may find washed up
six miles out on the horizon away from
the cameras an exclusion zone for a
complex recovery of debris over a seven
mile area
it was the locals here who captured a
moment which diplomatically represents
more than just a jolt in the difficult
chinese-american relationship that's my
Air Force right there buddy the incident
now has two distinct strands first the
recovery of this the balloon's payload
meteorological apparatus say the Chinese
sophisticated spy Tech say The Americans
and it'll take a flotiller of specialist
ships with divers a few days to recover
it's thought the debris will be brought
here to the U.S Marine base at Quantico
Virginia
this is home to the FBI's forensics lab
where investigators will examine and
attempt to reconstruct what they find
there is posturing on both sides with
the Chinese suggesting there'll be
nothing to find the Americans claiming
that they've already gleaned important
intelligence from the balloons flight
the biggest strand to all of this is the
politics the diplomacy the Chinese
Embassy in Washington serves as an
example of The Frayed relations between
these two superpowers because inside
there is no Ambassador Beijing saw no
hurry to replace Qing gang who left to
become China's foreign minister last
month
the statement from the Chinese
government says it all China expresses
its strong dissatisfaction and protest
against the US's use of military force
to attack civilian unmanned airships
a defense Ministry spokesman added we
solemnly protest this move by the U.S
side and reserve the right to take
necessary measures to deal with similar
situations
U.S Secretary of State Tony blinken was
due in Beijing this weekend the
beginning of what was thought to be an
attempt by both sides to rebuild a
relationship that impacts us all
on America's Sunday shows the Republican
chair of the Senate intelligence
committee this is deliberate they did
this on purpose they understood that it
was going to be spotted and the message
they're trying to send the world is look
these guys can't even do anything about
a balloon flying over U.S airspace in
the days ahead we'll learn what the
Americans say was on that balloon
diplomatically a meaningful U.S China
reset now seems far off Mark Stone Sky
News in Quantico Virginia